I'll get right back now okay
it's
[Music]
okay this
variant is not uh EO so you can see the
Y hand is on the
forearm not on the
elbow and this variant is different from
the Niko
Keon
okay so as I come
around you're seeking contact point in
his Center this this hand has to control
his Center you have to seize his Center
so I'm reconciling the grip I get to the
outside and then we we we're connected
right now so he can't push at
me you can stand up
we I'm in that Co you thing okay he's
down and and of course you can project
but here I'm equating the the uh y value
of his body and taking him into the
spiral okay this is assisted by the
other hand so as the two hands are doing
this I'm not trying to slam them right
here because I'm standing right in front
of him and I always want this fight to
spiral rotate so he has to go past
okay and that gives me the opening for
the E
Eng so if you don't if you don't have
your ability to touch something and
touches Center this technique you're
going to have a hard time with it that's
why we're doing it okay so I come around
and you're in Center I'm not slamming
them down here I personally don't have
thumbs my thumbs were br broken in the
'90s they don't
work and if I try to torque his body
here uh it hurts my thumbs and he just
slowly he can overpower me he's going to
get out of it cuz I don't have it so
you're not you don't want to use your
strength because even if you did not
have broken thumbs like
me uh somebody could always outow that
joint it's just a very very inferior
joint so you don't crank here you you
move that you move his body okay you
move his body and then we take him into
the E ending which we're ending this way
and I want to get there but right now
pay attention to this beginning
around in moving him enter slide up to
the
elbow and we can stop there what we
want around
hold slides it's like in knife training
don't come off and on just slide
up and we'll stop
there boom right into the
body in techniqu
St okay make that distinction
go okay so as I'm working these these
forces here it's it's these it's the
forces uh on his body the internal
forces on his body it's not the uh
skeletal muscular uh working of his
joint CU I I'm not strong enough you see
but when we're in this process do you
see um and I'm not trying to just use my
thumb to hold here or I'm not trying to
crank down here he's he's just with you
can see how open my grip is so I am
cutting vectors through his body and so
maybe get closer on this hand too so you
can see where's where's his thumb
where's his thumb okay that's what you
want to know okay and so those forces
are working in him and if we were moving
those forces are greater so he still
can't stand up
try but it's not the same thing as he
better go down cuz I'm going to break
his wrist do do you get that if if he
stands up like I want you to slowly uh
TR try to do it and and then tap when
you don't like it on your body you see
it's still on but it's not on by the
same mechanisms okay uh and that's
important because people are strong and
this is a very weak engine a skeletal
engine so make sure you're doing that
correctly cuz even even in Kempo when he
used to you do n or me in Kempo we had
one technique where you just here you
just and you just rip it out and you're
you're now free to hit that guy okay um
and where did I come out of the thumb
the thumb is a weak point that you
always come out of when grip escapes
okay so make sure you're not here trying
to crank on this that's not the
technique but this is the technique okay
you can still make him top with it you
see he's still doing
it but we're not cuz we're doing
something else here all right so we get
here and I want to work
on the
um
transitions I don't want to see this I
go here he lays down lays himself down
and then you're doing this you see that
to me la la
because he is the one who lay
down I'm actually picking him up if you
watch your shoulder you see that now
that's not the
technique
boom as we come around
okay if you I I exaggerate how much
control I actually have
so if he tries to stand
up he's he's not going to you see as we
go into the technique we're here stand
up same thing you see stand up same
thing try to stand up it's not going to
stand up do you see try to stand up try
to stand up it's not going to stand up
try to stand up it's not going to stand
up you understand so it looks like it's
loose but it's not loose because of the
same control mechanisms I'm using on the
first technique so we go here boom and
it looks like it's loose you see and
he's laying down do that side
again as we go you try I'll do it a
little more movement and you try to
stand the whole time
do you understand okay so that theory
that's called control maintenance and I
maintain control my intention here is to
pin him not lift him back up so no
energy should be coming back up all
energy is going down and which way
forward forward down and forward because
of the non-c contestation 90°
fluctuation that I always have to do so
it's not straight down but it is always
going down down and also going forward
okay try again okay in this training uh
I'll ask UK to fill any Yin space
because if you're going down and forward
there's no Yin space for UK to get up do
you guys understand that okay so uh this
will help train you for your uh
sensitivity as UK but it will expose
That Someone's Not does not have that
constant yangong which is basically the
p
the whole pinning assumption that you're
doing I'm going down and I'm going down
the whole time okay so UK I'm not asking
you to fight or overly counter I'm just
if you feel some Yin space that can let
you get up I want you to come up okay go
don't want you laying at the
bottom so there's some there's some
upward when you pass it over
okay better get it on this side
still there it's still there a little
okay it's it's on your
uh your hand towards your feet we'll
call that the rear hand
um your rear hand is not doing the elbow
uh control with the knife edge and the
bicep control on the wrist it's it's
letting them up it's loose okay so uh
let me show you what I mean not too long
ago uh when we were here remember that
we did that it's the same exact thing
here so I have EO EO wrist and elbow
control but I have it with one arm see
this is why I do this throw
along okay the same thing here when I
come around boom
around you're going to give up that you
see so this don't give up the elbow the
hand that's on the elbow is simply going
to turn this way so right now I still
have the Eco elements wrist control
elbow
control I start to change it it's still
wrist and elbow control do you guys see
that and when I put it here it's still
wrist and elbow control it's just right
there do you guys got it so you lose the
elbow when you lose the eeko go back
with few seconds you come here and you
go like that it came off you'll never
get back on in real life okay so you
keep the elbow Bo I stay on that elbow
and there's never time when you can lift
the shoulder because there's always a
downward pressure on the elbow okay try
it but like EO it's balanced with the
wrist
hi there you
go yeah see you you have a weird idea on
the elbow
[Music]
see how it comes it's so you have some
coming back energy that's what he filled
okay and it's on that elbow control it
looks like your in your mind you're
thinking uh bring the arm close to me
yes but do it on the positive side of
the circle don't rewind the circle and
go to the negative side of the circle do
do you guys understand that okay so
that's your mistake yes it does get
close but it gets close by going forward
into the circle not backwards into the
circle if you go backwards into the
circle you're going to generate Yin
space and the dude's going to get up
okay try it
again keep going forward better
[Music]
good
good we're just there okay so we go
here and if I bring my arm back if you
pay attention you see that I'm bringing
it back it's going backwards in space
you see that just track my hand
give it a vertical plane it's going
backwards it was going this way and now
it's going this way you see that and yes
it's now touching me where you guys want
it but you can get there by continuing
to go
forward this
way this way you see there it is
touching me again go
back and we know
if I go backwards you see see how the
hands going backwards I don't even I
don't want you to stand up here just
relax I'm going backwards do you see as
I pass it around and where is the
elbow it's on the back side it's on the
back side of my spine and for katama it
has to be on the front side of my spine
this has to be over here and there's
absolutely no way I can go backwards and
put it over there I have to go forward
again that stuff do doesn't work so
we'll rewind the film a
little and if I go forward you can see
that it's in the right
place
okay so all I'm doing is continuing to
forward forward into here not backwards
into here okay try
it all right so we had a question on
where does the initial Tachi fit within
the yinyang uh torso grid that we use
okay so my arm starts at yangong at the
shoulder okay uh you can move off the
line if you want to doesn't matter
usually I just do it very subtly inside
okay and so the rules are I started
there I know this hand wants to touch it
which means where what does this hand
have to do it has to bring it to the
center line so it brings it to the
center line and now I can do it okay
some things you don't want to do and you
you guys speak loud enough so the camera
can hear you uh what's wrong with
thats it's outside the Y Line so it's
outside the outer rim that is incorrect
uh what's wrong with
that I reached across do you see that
this hand can't touch it it doesn't
touch on the other side of the yin Yong
GD so as I'm moving I'm here again you
can put it in the area you just can't
start using it okay you can even touch
it so to speak if you're near there but
it's on my center line here I don't want
to
go that stuff
so same
thing again I take small angles this is
sh 10 Con on that one same thing right I
could go out here but I'm touching it
but I'm not using
it till it gets to the center line then
I can start using
the ten con gave me the angle deviation
you can't go out but it's always going
to be the same okay start at the Young
line move towards the middle line then
the other hand can take over and or
assist okay